[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
guillotiné vos dirigeants
c'est ce qu'à mes amis le jour de son
pot de départ à la retraite
il faut toujours aller au pot de départ
à la retraite parce que les gens disent
la vérité sur leur carrière
a répondu à un parterre de jeunes
médecins africains qui lui demandait
quel était son ultime recommandations
pour améliorer les conditions de vie des
populations
c'est une boutade bien sûr très
française c'est la mort du roi qui ouvre
une nouvelle période et que vous voulez
dire ce spécialiste tout simplement que
le développement ou l'émergence comme on
dit aujourd'hui à des préalables
politiques ou sociaux politiques et que
ces préalables ce ne sont pas réunies
dans la plupart des pays africains
donc le discours que vous entendez
régulièrement à la télévision ou bien
que vous entendez aussi lors de vos
voyages en afrique quand les politiques
parlent c'est une fable en ce sens que
ce n'est pas un discours qui vise à
décrire une réalité mais qui vise à
édifier donc ce qu'ils entendent
c'est ce que je voudrais partager avec
vous ce soir alors tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que l'émergence
c'est une notion extrêmement vague mais
qui s'est imposé à l'origine via des
milieux financiers en gros les marchés
émergents ce sont les marchés qui sont
plus rentables que les vieux marché
européen africain où certains asiatiques
comme le japon ont appliqué cette motion
à des pays qui sont quand même très
avancées comme le
le brésil la corée du sud voire israël
et peu à peu on l'a transposé à
l'afrique
non on n'a pas de définition précise
mais au fond on va la comprendre or à
comprendre cette notion comme le
rapprochement du niveau de vie des
populations sur une période longue avec
celui des anciens pays industrialisés
alors on parle de corée du sud on parle
d'israël en parle de brésil comment est
ce qu'on a pu passer à l'afrique alors
tout simplement parce que l'afrique a
recommencé à connaître une croissance
forte à partir des années 90 alors je
dis bien recommencer il faut avoir en
tête n'ont qu'une hirondelle ne fait pas
le printemps parce que ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'afrique connaît une
forte vague de croissance
je vais pas vous assommer avec des
chiffres mais en gros on peut se
rappeler que des indépendances à azzan
et 75 la crise pétrolière
le revenu par habitant augmente et
ensuite il a chuté jusqu'au milieu des
années 90 et désormais ils redémarrent
mais ce qu'on rattrape en fait c'est le
temps perdu parce que c'est seulement en
2009 rendez vous compte que le revenu
par habitant en afrique a retrouvé son
niveau de 74 donc on rattrape un peu le
temps perdu dans le passé on ne ratera
pas les pays que je l'appellerai
vraiment émergents puisque par exemple
le revenu par tête entre l'afrique et
l'asie continuent de s'écarter
donc il ya toujours un écart croissant
entre ses deux revenus
c'est moins le cas pour amériques de
l'amérique latine par rapport à
l'afrique mais c'est quand même toujours
le cas on ne ratera pas l'amérique
latine autre problème
le taux de pauvreté a diminué en afrique
qu'est ce qu'on appelle le taux de
pauvreté c'est la part des pauvres dans
la population
mais comme il ya une très forte
croissance démographique et qui a assez
peu d'emplois il en faudrait 30 millions
environ par an pour absorber tous les
jeunes qui arrivent
le nombre de pauvres le nombre absolu a
augmenté de 50 % sur 25 ans vous voyez
c'est considérable donc c'est quand même
très abusif de parler d'émergence
quand vous avez un nombre de pauvres qui
augmente ce qui n'est le cas nulle part
ailleurs
d'ailleurs la banque mondiale considère
qu'en 2050 l'afrique pourrait concentrer
90 % des pauvres du monde
alors pourquoi on a parlé création
d'emplois ce qui a eu de particulier en
afrique c'est qu'il ya une croissance
importante + 2 5 % on la trouve enviable
jeudi 6 mai qu'elle ne s'est pas
accompagnée des modifications qui font
habituellement l'émergence c'est-à-dire
l'intensification de l'agriculture
je me rappelle m'être promené en afrique
avec un membre du gouvernement français
il s'étonnait de voir qu'on utilisait
encore la bêche quelle salade à bas et
qu'on transportait les denrées avec des
petits ânes
il n'y a pas eu d'industrialisation il
ya même eu une désindustrialisation
précoce c'est à dire que les quelques
industries qui s'était mise en place
dans les années 70 ont été très
fortement concurrencé et ont beaucoup
souffert
il ya eu certes de belles poussées dans
le domaine du tertiaire ce sont les
fameuses start up
il ya eu des avancées en matière de
banque de télécommunications c'est
appréciable c'est remarquable mais ça
n'augmente pas beaucoup la productivité
de l'économie et ça ne touche pas la
grande partie de la population
dernier point il ya même des doutes
si vous voulez sur la réalité sur
l'importance de cette croissance
il ya un économiste qui s'appelle morton
gerven qui a fait des travaux très
précis très ennuyeux très long sur les
statistiques des pays anglophones et qui
a montré au fond on avait peut-être
sur sous-estimé la croissance dans les
années 90 on n'a pas tenu compte de la
développement du secteur informel et
donc quand on a tenu compte dans les
années 2000 d'un mathématiquement on a
surestimé cette croissance donc on a
retiendra que il faut prendre tout ça
avec des pincettes et que l'économiste
hamidou and dit qu'au fond il ya une
série de petits à l'o2 lueur d'espoir de
faim de petit clignotant mais qui ne
font pas un véritable à l'eau alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait les
promesses n'ont pas été tenues comme je
pourrais vous le montrer il y a eu donc
peu de transformations là je vous montre
une plantation de palmiers à huile
je les visite est dans les années 90 on
m'a dit que 20 ans avant elle marchait à
fond usine marché à toute vitesse
il y avait des cadres qui avaient une
cité de cadre incroyable y avait des
emplois les villageois étaient contents
vingt ans après plus rien ne plus rien
de marché et j'ai été très frappé j'ai
bu un verre autour de la piscine des
cadres il y avait il y avait dedans des
lianes autre point je voulais vous
amener à abidjan j'ai visité à abidjan
limites de la pyramide alors qui a été
fait avec l'argent du cacao des grandes
années c'était magnifique c'était
l'entrée de la côte d'ivoire dans la
modernité et dans les fêtes il n'a pas
pu être entretenue et c'est devenu cet
cette vilaine carcasses qui subsistent
mais à côté des immeubles plus moderne
alors en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que l'afrique a bénéficié donc d'un
certain nombre de facteurs extérieurs
favorable ces facteurs on les connaît on
d'abord l'argent et abondants on paye
pas cher ces crédits c'est ce que vous
voyez
voyez vous même le cours des matières
premières est élevé vont vous voyez
quand vous passez
à la pompe et puis ça vous le voyez
moins en france il ya une importance
considérable de l'investissement chinois
et tout ça donc à susciter une forte
croissance mais tout ça pourrait être
passager est un économiste américain qui
s'appelle dani rodrik et qui dit qu'on
pourrait être une croissa une croissance
qui deviendrait un moteur son carburant
alors ce qui est inquiétant c'est que
cet endettement a permis de doper la
croissance notamment en faisant des
investissements publics
alors on entend parler dans la presse
souvent la france y participe comme des
lignes de deux ter des villes nouvelles
mais que souvent ces investissements
sont d'une rentabilité extrêmement
douteuse seront chères à payer est plus
grave que ça dans certains cas on a mis
en évidence des surfacturations
absolument énorme
dans un pays comme le cameroun sur les
cinq projets majeurs émergence du
gouvernement la banque mondiale a
calculé qu'il y avait un taux de
surfacturation de 2 à 6 c'est totalement
énorme ça rien à voir avec nos petits
15% sur les ronds-points là qui faisait
la une dans l'époque de jean montaldo
vous voyez c'est absolument considérable
alors si on ne doit pas donc prendre ce
discours pour argent comptant on doit
aussi quand même s'interroger sur le
pourquoi de cette absence de changement
de fond et on revient la proposition que
je vous avais fait c'est à dire
l'absence de conditions socio politiques
adéquates il faut toujours travailler
même si comparaison n'est pas raison en
regardant ce qui se passe ailleurs et on
a vu que partout ailleurs en europe aux
etats unis c'est moins net mais en asie
ça a été très net
il ya eu une accélération réel du
développement une mutation profonde des
économies quand il ya eu une
configuration socio politiques adéquates
à savoir une concordance une convergence
d'intérêts entre la bourgeoisie qui peut
se faire appuyés par des investisseurs
extérieurs bourgeoisie d'affaires
nouveau châssis capitaliste
le gouvernement l'armée parfois ça a été
le cas en thaïlande et une partie des
travailleurs qui tire partie donc de
cette augmentation du niveau de vie dans
la plupart des pays africains on le voit
en lisant la presse on a du mal à
imaginer qu'une quelle configuration
soit en place alors on cite des exemples
intéressants
l'ethiopie le rwanda alors il faut être
toujours très circonspect parce que même
s'il ya pas de fatalité africaine on
voit que les premiers de la classe
change souvent
alors prenons le rwanda on a un pays qui
a été mis en place comme vous le savez
après le génocide qui a arrêté le
génocide
c'est un pays à un pouvoir donc
minoritaire qui a donc tout intérêt à
développer le pays sérieusement pour
asseoir sa légitimité
mais quoi de commun entre un le pouvoir
de kagame est par exemple le pouvoir
qu'on retrouve dans un certain nombre de
vieilles dictatures ou démocrature
d'afrique centrale où on a un certain
nombre de régimes finissants qui capte
très rapidement une rente pétrolière qui
va d'ailleurs déclinant quels points
communs aussi entre le rwanda pays
extrêmement organisés quadrillé
contrôler et le sahel dont on entend
parler régulièrement on a des pays dont
l'incurie des régimes a fait des
victimes toutes désignées du djihadisme
donc vous voyez bien que parler
d'émergence c'est extrêmement abusif
même s'il ya des espoirs et même si on
peut croire bien sûr à terme à l'afrique
parce qu'encore une fois il ya bien
évidemment pas de fatalité
alors la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est pourquoi ce discours c'est il
diffuse et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
l'entend régulièrement à la télévision
notamment et pourquoi est ce qu'il ya
des limites des spécialistes de ce
discours qui en vivent dans j'essayerai
de pas devenir un spécialiste du contre
discours mais c'est ce que je fais quand
même aujourd'hui je crois que il ya pas
mal de raisons la première c'est que
l'occident est un peu en désarroi on a
besoin de nouvelles donc si on nous dit
que des pays qu'on a et dès qu'on a
colonisé sont sur la route de
l'émergence du développement c'est quand
même rassurant
sa légitime l'aide l'argent qu'on a mis
pendant 40 ans dans ces pays
en ce qui concerne la france on nous
reproche parfois d'avoir un tropisme
africain au nom d'une certaine nostalgie
coloniale ça nous permet de répondre non
écoutez on n'est pas des nostalgiques on
a été simplement des visionnaires on a
vu avant tout le monde que l'afrique
allait devenir le nouveau marché mondial
puis le dernier point je crois qu'on est
dans un certain ben idéologique
alors on parle de la france comme start
up nacion je crois que ça fait débat au
fond on essaye de nous parler de du
continent africain comme un startup
continent et avec l'idée au fond que la
politique ça ce n'est pas très important
et que l'essentiel c'est l'entreprise et
la technologie que si l'entreprise
marche il technologie se déploie et bien
tout sera résolu c'est ce qu'on appelle
dans certains cas le discours néolibéral
donc je crois que ce sont les raisons
essentielles
alors tout ça nous avance pas beaucoup
pour l'avenir parce que donc on a des
soucis sur l'avenir de l'afrique sur sa
sécurité sur la possibilité d'une vague
migratoire mais je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement humble à partir du moment où
on est persuadé que ce sont des
mécanismes socio politique complexe qui
déterminent l'avenir de l'afrique
il est très difficile d'avoir une vision
globale
il est difficile très difficile de
prévoir quoi que ce soit comme disent
les philosophes de l'histoire l'histoire
et les contingents dont on ne sait pas
trop où elles valent alors on a quand
même quelques pistes on voit que les
pays qui se développent plus vite que
d'autres serein développement pour la
risée en afrique par exemple on parle du
kenya du rwanda de l'ethiopie parfois de
la côte d'ivoire mais il ya des nuages
qui s'accumulent et donc en ce qui
concerne les migrations
on peut penser qu'elles seront d'abord
essentiellement intra africaines
ensuite est-ce qu'on aura des grandes
vagues migratoires vers l'europe
vous savez que ça a donné lieu à
polémique là aussi il faut être
extrêmement humble ça dépendra de
beaucoup de facteurs les facteurs on les
connaît mais je voudrais en citer
soumettre un facteur de plus cher qu'on
cite bien sûr c'est la montée des
nationalismes la xénophobies comme en
pologne en hongrie là il est bien
évident que c'est dissuasif
on cite le durcissement des politiques
migratoires
c'est vrai quoi que le durcissement n'a
pas toujours eu les résultats escomptés
mais il ya un élément nouveau vous avez
vu que les pays européens et notamment
la france avec un certain retard se sont
engagés dans une politique de
libéralisation du marché du travail et
vous voyez cas auparavant le phénomène
de calais s'était essentiellement dû au
fait que les migrants
bien sûr anglophones ce qui les aidaient
était attiré par le marché du travail
extrêmement flexible extrêmement
dérégulé en angleterre et donc je pense
que l'une des incidences de la politique
de libéralisation qui est en cours c'est
peut-être aussi de créer un appel d'air
vers la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]